Now, how do we display it?
This is the image I got,
captures a lot more gory detail.
It's no longer from 0 to 255.
What I want, of course, is an image
that can be still displayed because
displays also have the same constraints
as cameras and printers do that.
I still need to be able to put up
colors between 0 to 255 for each and
every one of the channel's RGB.
So this is what we want out of it.
Just to zoom in,
here is the image that you should now
actually have the details here, right?
You can see details of the painting.
They're all well lit.
You can see the snow outside and
it's well lit outside.
You can even see, for example,
the umbrella outside in detail but
you can also see details of the floor
and everything else like that.
I personally love this
image it's it's a nice,
of course, background and backdrop.
We'll be making these
example images available for
you to play around with too.